in some ways I've always been interested
in people who have a hard time
communicating their emotions and maybe
the the sort of quote/unquote normal way
you know something with the musical is
you you kind of can resort to song and
dance to communicate those emotions in a
way that words can't and with Neal I
think it was there was such poetry I
think for me just looking at his life in
the sort of story of someone who in many
cases seemed to sublimate his emotions
into his work and into this passion that
he had ever since he was a little boy of
Av passion for aviation and this is
someone who learned how to fly before he
learned how to drive Ryan and I spent
some time up in the cornfields in Ohio
where he grew up at his old farmhouse
where he grew up and you know it's not
in the movie but it kind of informed a
lot of what we did in the movie where
you just go there you see these see the
sea of you know flat cornfields and this
giant sky you can kind of immediately
understand why Ohio produces more
astronauts than any other any other
state in the u.s. any other part of the
world we went in to the astronaut Hall
of Fame we were all there to do some
some training and the the young ladies
showing us around was like hey you know
all your guys are in there you can go
see the plaque of your guy and and we
went in and I might get into some
spoilers here but it is historical so we
got in there and I play Elliott C so I
was looking around for Elliott and then
I realized like all the plaques have
mission patches underneath them and
Elliott never got to fly a mission and
it it struck me pretty profoundly being
in that room and I missed Elliott when I
was in there looking at all the
astronauts but all the all the
characters in this are so rich and we're
lucky enough at least myself personally
for deke slayton there's so much
information and there's there's so much
you can go to youtube and look at all
these conferences and and his his his
past is really well recorded and so you
could really get in there and find
things to ground yourself so I really
enjoyed doing this character because I
felt like I was I had cinderblocks on my
feet to get to play a woman that is both
strong and on the team and and not in
the shadows and then also shown to be
vulnerable I mean that's like an
incredible character so yeah that was
definitely what attracted to me the role
and I think Josh really made a point of
that in his story to have it be about
the family not just the man yeah Janet
and Pat and all the women who were left
at home were extraordinary but I think
it takes a filmmaker like Damian who
those stories are there it's not like
they didn't they those women were always
there just nobody was interested you
know the story was here the story was
with the men who were going to the moon
and that's what I think the films are
amazing doing is the humanity of the men
who were going was also not that
important to anybody nobody really
wanted to know that they had lives and
that they had arguments with their wives
and their kids and you know all those
things and I think it takes a filmmaker
to shine the light on that and say that
that's the real story really that's a
story we wanted to know we don't want to
know what we've been told and fed and
you know makes us believe in heroes and
that all these people have superpowers
we want you know and I have I don't I
can't read a script that's like that I'm
afraid if you look at it in terms of the
rocks that we collected the experiments
that we set up and those type of things
it's a it's a it's a tough question but
if you look at it in terms of what would
what I think we see which is it inspired
and motivated an entire generation of
people to want to be better it made them
want to work harder because great things
could happen and and dreams could come
true and if you just take that and you
multiply that by the number of people
across the world it's a very very
powerful thing it was I mean it was it
was sort of an extension of that space
camp in the sense that we were given
every opportunity to
to feel what what they felt as close as
as close as we could get while we were
filming a movie you know when to have al
worden who was Apollo 15 astronaut right
they're telling us you know this is when
you flip the switch or and then to look
out the window and you see pretty much
what we're seeing in the movie was
incredible the theremin was actually a
really big find personally because I was
looking for points of connection with
Neil and I wasn't it was hard to relate
to you know his genius his courage his
humility because those are so
extraordinary I was looking for things
that that I we had in common and and we
have the theremin nobody really talks
about or at least I haven't seen it yet
is is how supportive the wives were of
one another that was that was a that was
a key piece of making that work and
there there's a scene where I think you
and then you two in Maryland see or
think to think in your house and that
kind of stuff happened all the time and
the the wives really were the one
because the guys were gone and we're
gone locked and and they were the only
ones that could you know sort of relate
to one another and help each other out
and that's that's a very important story
and a very important contribution that
making the whole thing work